[Musik]
lesen
herzlich kommt seien völlig veraltet wir
sind heute in düsseldorf im medienhafen
und wer den kanal schon eine weile
verfolgen weiß was das bedeutet mag
gebauer
gekommen zu dem anschlag der effekt
leite perfekt egal was passiert wenn wir
schon mal hier kurz man darüber nicht
denn wir haben heute hier einen ein
ferrari porto
[Musik]
eheleute steht für ist italienisch bei
ferrari ist klarheit herrschen oder
modifikation modifiziert das interessant
auch wo die pkk also es weiblich quasi
ist es in die die sagen die auto also
lama china macht ja und leute was
verfolgst jetzt zudem zu dieser
folierung für die gut
denn ich habe an alle fans natürlich
etwas zu verkünden werden ab jetzt jedes
auto was ich hole wenn wir in dieser in
dieser art und weise machen
bitte lasst auf hinterlasst dieser folie
paar gute reviews und den kommentaren
denn es war geil leuten wird ein
bisschen geräte ist mir egal ob ja dann
sagen was wir wollen ja ich liebe diese
folierung ich finde ja ich finde auch
geläute ich verstehe auch was ihr meint
ich habe vorher mal ad hoc vom markt
gesehen hat man nur die tür gesehen da
ich auch okay aber ich kann nicht sagen
und ich hoffe ihr glaubt mir das in life
sieht die folie geil aus und übrigens
leute thema auto hier haben wir in alten
bekannten quasi zumindest unter der
motorhaube ist nämlich der gleiche motor
wie im ferrari roma 3,9 liter v8 biturbo
wir haben wie im roma 620 ps 67
newtonmeter handy klingelt auch schon
ganz schön gut ja also soundmäßig und
ich sagen kann ich schon überzeugen ja
und macht schon spaß auch damit
rumzufahren ja also das ist
multiplikator wieder dass der
modifizierte portofino der ursprüngliche
portofino war ja quasi ein
weiterentwickelter nachfolger vom
california at wir haben die neue kolben
ansaugung und motorsteuerung
überarbeitet vom california at daraus
oder den wahren
terraria fiktionale war der kalifornier
war super ja auf jeden fall ja
eigentlich der der favorit überhaupt und
wo und so das war gar nicht so
interessant noch eine sache die ich dazu
sagen will also bitte auch schreibt mir
nicht so fielen die kommentare sie
können ihre meinung sagen aber so was
wie ja einsteiger ferrari oder so leute
hört euch das ding mal live an was was
jetzt hast du denn dass der billigste
ferrari natürlich das müssen die leute
in die kommentare heute müssen schreiben
das ist doch der billigste vergehen mit
ja genau schreibt alle in die kommentare
von mir hat es nicht gereicht danke dann
sind wir alle froh für übrigens mal also
200.000 euro roundabout basispreis der
kommt zu 240 wir stehen ja ist eine
richtig geile kiste porto übrigens oder
portofino vitalia sein ist eine
hafenstadt in italien ist ein kleines
dorf da liegen dann in der bucht immer
die geisteskranken yachten da war ich
auch schon mal ja deswegen heißt der
fall so gab es übrigens auch mal habe
ich herausgefunden auch mal ein lambo
lamborghini portofino das war so eine
konzeptstudie aus den 80ern werde ich
alles mal einen drauf wir haben 250 r
reifen hinten 25 40 vorne übrigens fun
fact leute wir haben es heute mit mark
getroffen um 13 uhr jetzt ist 16.30 aber
das lag nur an dir ja nur du warst das
schult ja also ich sag mal so er wollte
so rechtskommission vorgehen er hat sie
nicht will nicht mehr also wieso
eigentlich daran dass wir noch das auto
waschen mussten ja dann haben wir noch
solche geben sollte wissen dass wir
irgendwas mit dem auto dreht nein nein
nein so dachte sich mit dem medienhafen
anzuschauen auf einmal sicherste auto
leute chor von hinten alle gta spieler
werden es verstehen grotte carboni sarah
aus gta 5 ist doch dem roma sage ich dem
portofino nachempfunden ferrari hat
quasi das auto aus dem spiel nachgemacht
naja ist ja
hier keine lichter ich finde diese
abgesetzten auspuff dieser heckdiffusor
sind alles schon sehr aggressiv und
leute portofino es ist ja auch ein
cabrio ja also wir können eigentlich
direkt mal sondern aufmachen direkt mal
aufmachen dabei komme auf den soundcheck
machen kann sich motorrad anmache bei
der klingt wirklich gut wir hatten
obschon alle hatten partikelfilter sind
jetzt zu und jetzt
schauen wir ob das ein partikelfilter
klingt
jetzt
für italien geld hat immer irgendwie
andere regeln jetzt war das ist so geil
eröffnet jetzt hier so hoch
das ist doch eine so geile konstruktion
macht er jetzt das dach rein
dann schließt er wieder so zack bumm
richtig geil und also für das verdeck
aufmachen zu machen öffnet er so und man
kann dann auch wenn man hierauf macht
eröffnet einfach so rum also der kampf
musste noch einmal vorne arretieren so
erfüllen und dann so keller richtig geil
richtig geil und ich muss sagen mir
gefällt hier zum beispiel hat er den
gleichen motor wieder roma aber ich
finde die front hier viel geiler der
roma sieht so ein bisschen aus als hätte
also
egal über die fans nicht verraten
der roma hat ja so ein bisschen diese
diese schadlos dieses nach innen
abgeschrägte mir gefällt das persönlich
besser ja du hast ja auch schnell bei
lugner sehr nette jungs stimmt leute
auch mal schauen wann
lupo in düsseldorf mit den hab ich auch
schon gedreht du hast auch dein
portofino aus düsseldorf von lugner
genauer vom arzt des der beste mann ja
erst einmal ja dann sind auch gut aber
ich kenne ihn ja ich kenne nur sebastian
deswegen auch fuß gehen raus hat sich
sebastian von luke in düsseldorf es
kinder leute ich wäre ich gar nicht so
viele themen springt autor ein
fortkommen
das kann man schon heute okay das ist
das stichwort das ist aus wir sind hier
genau die leute engines auch dieses
lenkrad so geil auch hier eilt habt ihr
schon mal so einen geilen sonnenschutz
gesehen hier
mamma mia wirklich das ist so ein geiles
lediglich so ein geiles produkten
[Gelächter]
darum pilz aber ordentlich warm hier
italieners teil leute das homepage und
54 und
sehr sehr komfortable oder sehr
komfortabel das ist auch so finde ich
wenn jemand ein alltagsauto haben möchte
ja ja leute vergessen vergesst golf
variant
aber es ist jetzt kein aggressiver
sportwagen der hat 620 ps schon gesagt
hast ja aber wir sind hier wirklich ganz
entspannt ja du kannst das ding so
fahren wir können jetzt damit nach
münchen fahren wieder zurückkommen und
ihr wisst nicht halt komplett am ende so
mäßig ja das ist echt strong also ich
erinnere mich noch als ich damals in den
lambro von achronix eingestiegen bin
übrigens das ist ja auch wirklich bald
neues remix heute funktioniert leute den
hunger kann evo und der wirklich fast
das gefühl du
ich sag mal du errät die kippen marke
von dem sturm über den u bahnen ist ja
so ist so ist das fahrwerk das hält auch
das war auch damals die sache als dann
der gt3 dazu gekommen ist hatte ich dann
bei mir auch irgendwie habe ich dann da
musst du irgendwas komfortables ja
eigentlich wollte ich etwas anderes
haben aber irgendwie bin ich dann zu dem
auto gekommen und so das feedback auch
von den leuten muss ich sagen man könnte
davon ausgehen dass du dort zum beispiel
in form aus anderen erzählt er sagt ihr
bei mir die leute sind sehr positiv
reagieren sehr positiv darauf und
also was man aus teilen das geld
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also sehr komfortabel man fährt hier
wirklich also die straßen sind hier wo
wir grad langfahren düsseldorf
katastrophe bahnschienen über einiger
einmal das gefühl man fährt über den
kölner hauptbahnhof einmal klar drüber
übrigens stichwort hier das ist nicht
von ingo walther ist das neue parfüm von
marc erst bei kommt auf jeden fall
libyen kingking ranking leute und max
papis sind alle verlinkt erster linker
beschreibung check die auf jeden fall ab
dank anja manzoni launch control gemacht
ich weiß auch ganz viel diskutierte esel
und taste
[Musik]
der arbeitet dessen herz schützt und die
mit roten erste mal
der hat aber gut sich bewegte aber hallo
und das war nur sport sondern hat noch
race und nach erst auf
wenn du dein leben nicht mehr lieb ist
dann notwendig ist ja dass das ist schon
sagen auch jetzt für die leute die sich
fragen wie fährt zum auto
porsche ist will ich schon noch mal ein
bisschen ruhiger auf der straße und
meist ist es hat vielleicht auch damit
zu tun dass ich keiner das ist dass ich
jetzt nicht auto fahren kann aber ja ich
finde durch diesen frontmittelmotor das
auto ist ein bisschen unruhig ok also
bei höheren geschwindigkeiten wenn ich
so lenke und so ich habe immer das
gefühl so ein bisschen da ist mehr
action bei den porsche der ist ruhiger
auf der straße du hast es nicht fit ist
jetzt nicht oder du hast halt
prinzipiell will ich sagen vom konzept
her beim beim front oder vom mittelmotor
eher die tendenz dass ein bisschen mehr
vorn das meine ich da ja gar nicht dass
das habe ich auch weil du heute die
masse vorne hass der lenkeinschlag ist
aber auch sehr sexy er geht ja darum bis
zum wenig mehr ist hier einmal hier
unten genannten drücken und dann geht es
rückwärts
geil
also ich sag mal so kameras und sowas
das läuft auch alles tipptopp sieht gut
aus die warnsysteme assistenzsysteme ist
auch gut also da bin ich wirklich sehr
zufrieden und ja also kann man nicht
sagen es ist aber sehr komfortabel
wirklich und wenn man halt einmal also
dokus hier um 11 66 tonnen ja so viel
hat übrigens auch ziemlich genau der 92
gts cabrio leute frage an euch jetzt 9
und 2 gt s cabrio der ist zwar 40.000
günstiger als stellen der kostet 160
basis der 200 welchen würdet ihr nehmen
hersteller frage stellt euch vor es ist
ein nur ein auto davon haben ja wir
müssen fair sachlich fair machen das
auto musste eingesetzt werden die auch
im gts eingesetzt wird also als die
schon als der kannst also ich sag mal so
du kannst infernalischen als daily auch
nutzen ich finde übels com-portal so
kannst du machen natürlich nicht aber
ich ist eine schwierige fall bin ich ja
mal gespannt was die zuschauer da sage
ich schreibe meine kommentare und
schreibt auch gerne begründung dazu
werden dass man ausführen können und
wollte ich hier einmal tunnel leute ihr
seht wahrscheinlich zu viel von uns wenn
auch nicht so viel
geil ist das geil und der vision noch so
mit dem heck ist das geil alter
mama mir
richtig geil
also sportmodus richtig ist nichts
wunderschön und er gibt beschleunigen da
gibt es so klein publisher noch ist
einfach
gesagt
mega so der hektische asta und toleranz
die perfekte nicht drin als wird so
verquer sind
also leute wir haben heute leider ist
nicht so super die möglichkeit auch
gerade weil es in düsseldorf umfeld
nicht so viele freie autobahn gibt
übrigens typ dafür autobahn speed an
dass eine karte mit allen freien
autobahn
hier kann man den porto 40 mal
ansatzweise auswirkungen wissen durch
beschleunigen wir können viel gewinnen
aber ja klar nur das hier ist also leute
es wird schon dunkel auf jeden fall
markt vs drauf vielen finanzminister
weiter im super tag heute gehabt und
natürlich auch der typische info in
pattaya haben uns getroffen sind süße
essen ein auto waschen medienhafen
wieder zurück
raten mir leute das war's soweit voran
marc jaquet beschreibung und kanal wir
kommen jetzt zur bewertung können wir
damit zu bewerten leute und die beginnt
wie ihr bereits wisst immer mit dem
aussehen ich muss sagen der fairy
portofino m ist in meinen augen ein sehr
schönes auto ein bisschen was fehlt ihm
zu den zwei besten noten 9 oder 10
punkten gerade im profil ist das auto
aber wirklich wirklich sexy da ist da
ist den schon ein gutes stück gelungen
auf jeden fall einen kleinen
gedanklichen abstrich muss sich aber
dennoch für die folie geben die meiner
meinung nach nicht so schlimm ist wie
viele andere behaupten aber jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht die optimale wahl
für den wagen vielleicht einfach ein
einheitliches schwarz matt wäre
vielleicht dann noch besser gewesen aber
klar markt bringt ja auch seinen wagen
vollkommen verständlich acht von zehn
beschleunigung ist wie immer ein
einfacher schnack dreieinhalb sekunden
von null auf hundert das reicht für acht
von zehn ebenfalls damit können dann
logischerweise zu tun ist und ich muss
sagen auch wenn es ein paar stimmen gibt
die den portofino irgendwie in
misskredit stellen weil er so das
basismodell bei ferrari ist finde ich
denn auch das ist nach wie vor ein
vollwertiger ferrari und ein sehr cooles
auto klar ist natürlich dass er nicht an
die beste note 10 von 10 von zb ms ls
oder dem dem uhr außerdem 458 italia
rankommt aber neun von zehn dürfen sie
auf jeden fall sein macht möglicherweise
zusammen 25 von 30 punkten in der spaß
wertung und platz 12 und 21 was ich
schon fast bisschen zu hart für den
portofino anfühlt aber beim aussäen
rechtzeitig für neun von zehn und bei
der beschleunigung mathematisch auch
nicht für neun von zehn aber das sind
wirklich sehr sehr sehr starke 25 von 30
geiles auto damit der alltagswelt
umfange natürlich mit der
praktikabilität an und ich habe mich
ehrlicherweise dabei erwischt leute wie
ich den portofino um jeden preis auf 5
von 10 hoch boxen wollte und ich habe
tatsächlich ein paar gründe gefunden
auch vier von zehn hat der sls der ist
aber einfach einen deutlich älteres auto
ist der profil und damit unmittelbar
auch schon mal nämlich die technik
weniger praktisch denn ist ein gt r hat
fünf von zehn bekommen hat aber eine
absolut katastrophale ladekante und auch
nur 10 120 liter mehr im kofferraum also
leute ihr wisst bereits worauf es
hinausläuft fünf von zehn diskutiert
gerne in den kommentaren preis leistung
natürlich immer schwierig leute ihr
kennt den schlag 200.000 euro basispreis
roundabout sind echt schon ganz ganz
ganz krasse hausnummer aber dafür
bekommt man auch einen ferrari die
verarbeitung im innenraum finde ich
absolut sexy mein persönliches highlight
die sonnenblenden oh mein gott bitte
lass ich wünsche dir könnte das fühlen
einfach dazu noch die möglichkeit offen
zu fahren und den trotz op f richtig
geilen v 18 zu genießen das reicht in
meinen augen für 520 lust endlich beim
komfort hat ferrari mich mal wieder
überrascht der wagen kann wirklich sehr
sehr sehr entspannt bewegt werden ich
hätte damit auch gar keine probleme mit
200-300 vielleicht 400 kilometer zu
fahren nichtsdestotrotz ist es am ende
und ferrari und dadurch hat auch immer
sehr sportlich also fünf von zehn ist
okay okay macht am ende 15 30 in einen
für einen ferrari cabrio glaube ich ganz
erträglichen platz 15 von 21 in der
alltags wertung insgesamt kommen wir auf
40 von 60 punkten und dementsprechend 17
von 21 beachtet da aber dass da
natürlich auch die alltags wertung
ziemlich krass mit runterziehen am ende
muss ich ehrlich sagen der portofino
wenn ich meine erste wahl bei den
sportwagen oder bei den sport cabrios
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein sehr
sehr sehr gelungenes auto leute damit
verabschiede mich für diese woche ich
freue mich auf die nächste woche mit
euch macht's gut bis dahin und ja